okay awesome so first off thanks so much
to everybody who's put on tonight it's
been awesome the DJ's killing it
like everybody googled these places are
amazing if you haven't I recommend you
go try the bidet because those things
are so crazy oh my god
life changer too much okay so I think
Elizabeth mentioned a few things at the
beginning about what I do I'm Isaac I
work as an experienced engineer at leap
motion and so what that means to me is
like somewhere between even jealous and
like like reckless creator or something
like that because what I do is not so
much try to tell people that our
technology is cool but just be like so
in love with it that I can't help but
share it um I feel really bad for other
people who are even jealous and have to
like talk about a technology that they
don't really care about because like for
me it's like actually crazy how much I
love what I do
I'm trying something a bit different
with this talk and actually like wrote a
speech instead of just winging it so I
hope it still sounds ok but if it really
fails then I'll just make something up
okay oh the lights perfect okay so I'm
Isaac and I'm an experienced engineer at
leap motion I work exploring a newly
discovered relationship with our hands
I'm intensely interested in communing
with digital nature and the tools that I
used are 3ds Web Audio API and most of
all leap motion
most of what I can be done what I've
done can be found at Kiba comm where
I've been working on constructing my own
personal ice kingdom unlike our previous
speakers I have no idea what I'm doing
when they started talking about state
machines I was totally lost and my
understanding of equivalence rigorously
stops at two equal sides
don't worry though there's a reason
you've been asked to sit here and listen
to me for the next 30 minutes it's
because I'm addicted to coffee I love
coffee every day it's the first thing
that I consume in many days it's the
last I don't consume it because it's the
hardest drug I use I don't consume it
because it makes me feel them in like a
mental triathlete and I don't even
consume it because it tastes like the
delectable blood of an angel no I love
coffee because I love milk I also cannot
pronounce my eyes so it might sound a
lot like milk I love that milk is a
different consistency than coffee I love
that is differently colored than coffee
and I love that when I delicately
combine the two it creates the most
beautiful pattern I have ever seen it's
actually to the point of obsession I
never get hot coffee it makes the milk
dissipate too quickly and isn't as
likely to come in a clear glass regular
iced coffee isn't even enough I need
cold brewed condensed New Orleans I
style iced coffee only its viscosity
will satiate me
at the coffee shop I go to they make
sure they never put the milk in
themselves and always give me the
container to pour it drop by drop people
can't tell if I'm super conscious of my
milk consumption or just straight-up
weird the later is obviously the true
statement but it's mostly just because I
can't get over the mystical nature of
chaos it's kind of funny how this
turbulence brings me peace it's such a
lonely joy after all it's haunting dance
into nothingness is somehow melancholy
in my mind I think if it could be
because to me it's a firm reminder of
the unshakable arrow of time or vacuum
of space which are many ways terrifying
but it's just so damn beautiful that I
can do nothing but calm me maybe it's
because I can't unmix the milk and
coffee
maybe it's because when I mix the two
today they will look completely
different than they do tomorrow that one
magical tendril that I witnessed on the
first drop might be replaced with a
dendrite appearing only moments before
the completion of the sepia solution
maybe it's because any other individual
touching the glass will create a totally
different pattern they will never see
the same turbulence that I do
maybe it's because each and every
experience is only a single moment in a
single branch of infinite possibilities
unique and miraculous as it is or maybe
it's just the fact that after it's all
mixed I get to take that first sweet sip
and feel the delicious nectar of
caffeine flowing through my drugged
adult veins I hope it's the turbulence
though this would be a much more
interesting talk if it wasn't predicated
on a deep physical addiction either way
that moment when I watched the milk mix
I find myself in a happy place for that
moment rent is not important that giant
keep calm and carry on poster that is
now the centerpiece of our living room
doesn't bother me so much and I forget
how late I am to mine
stand up I find the turbulence in that
cup beautiful and that beauty makes me
happy not in an urgent way in an
important way I want that piece all the
time I want to go to my happy place 10
11 12 times a day and I've tried doing
that with coffee before it was a mistake
luckily as artists as I believe each and
every one of us are we can create that
happy place and we can go to it anytime
we want as magicians every time a silly
client tells us to use lime green to
make the text pop more we can just load
up a web page and experience peace
experience turbulence here's the thing
about turbulence though to get the
detail you see in coffee you need
infinite computing power to get each
precise flume and dexterous wrinkle you
need to get all the way to the atomic
level we can get close but we can't be
exact
sure you have scientists doing brilliant
work on subjects like Rayleigh Bernard
convection but even in their brilliance
they fall well short of exact
replication the butterfly effect as
we've all learned from the brilliant
scientist Ashton Kutcher is quite a
powerful one indeed and he just looks so
good in that picture floating point air
is painfully inaccurate when compared
with nature's uncertainty Planck's
length in the end if I believe that
turbulence is the most beautiful art
nature is the most beautiful artist it
can not only create turbulence but the
snow dappled mountains the powerful
rushing rivers in every heart-wrenching
sunset nature is awesome
nature is so awesome in fact that I've
seriously considered giving up computers
to become a gardener
they are the artists in my mind who have
chosen the truest medium anyone who has
spent time in the bonsai garden over by
Lake Merritt will certainly agree the
twists are more elegant than any Bezier
curve could hope to convey in the shear
detail of the turtle Barca
makes even the most processor intensive
physics simulation look like a crayon
drawing any one of us could spend our
entire life trying to create that turtle
bark and still fall dramatically short
of our goal hell all of us in this room
together could combine our superpowers
and attempt to conjure a tree and
nature's shaders would triumph without
competition if we were physical artists
on the other hand we could use the
physical nature of our work in order to
introduce some of the beauty of chaos
back before I understood that suit
computers gave you superpowers I used to
just spray paint on vegetable oil
splatter it on a canvas and call that
texture art and it was in many ways more
than what I create now at an even higher
level I tried to sample the texture of
an elephant's hide or a toad skin
sampling nature in this time was many
times beautiful it felt profound to
watch the flow of the Voronoi cells of a
dragonflies wing slowly unfurl into
existence as I painstakingly etched them
into middle but even this was a separate
away from the original even this was a
simulacra the further I went away I got
from milk mixing with coffee the more I
gave me creative power and nature less
by doing this I had to exert my own will
upon the art that I was creating and
that meant that nature was doing less
work and I was doing more since I'm lazy
and since we've established that nature
is a much better artist than I am
creating in this way is
ridiculous I was trying to say the thing
that I could both pause it and execute
was better than a trillion years of
artistic honing generations upon
generations of evolutionary pruning a
masterpiece older than time itself the
closest I could get was mimicry or
possibly borrowing I could not
understand how the paint mixed with the
oil but I could see that when I
haphazardly threw them on the canvas it
created something that felt important I
could not make the elephant itself but I
could trace a picture of its skin take
him from nature what I could not create
myself in this way to be good artists to
be good creators we do not need to be
good makers rather we need to be good
thieves the Voronoi cells the elephant's
texture and the swirling paint mixture
were after all the creation of nature
and for me to harness it in my work and
call it my own was to steal it from the
world itself this may seem like a
cardinal crime but as we've established
anything less is preposterous
what we do is another step away from
nature typically when creating a program
the functions we create and tasks we
accomplish have nothing to do with the
logarithmic structure of fern or the
Fibonacci arrangement of flower petals
it's all about paragraph tags and href
sand targets equals underscore blank we
are the ones that place these tags on
the page we are the ones who create
functions and methods objects that use
objects and as we build up this shoddy
tower of babel we tend to forget how
much more complex the system of an
ecosystem is and how much less energy it
would take the destroyer our work than
that of nature even when we create
recursive function and use math as the
language of nature adding one more layer
of complexity can easily crash our
computer limiting our detail to quite
childish standards let's not even begin
to talk about the fact that we're
limited to two dimensional space and
that know how no matter how many DPI
your screen is it is still crude
compared to the even the smallest grain
of sand under the examination of our
retinas in this way our medium is quite
pathetic by any measure of detail even
if we are disabled nature as a
background or a texture we are limited
by pixels memory and rendering power
instead of the rugged shape of an
elephant's ear we have to make spheres
and cubes and make sure that the
subdivisions are only of a certain
amount otherwise our rendering time will
drop beneath the already pathetic 60
frames a second even altered koalas and
mr. doobs bump map face is dramatically
less detailed than anybody in the crowds
this is not to say it is any less
amazing I think all of you can agree
that that is actually absurd it is just
to say that whenever we do anything are
in our medium we will fall short when we
try to mimic movement when we crop try
to create geometry and most of all when
we try to imitate turbulence I hope this
is disheartening it means that we have a
long way to go our struggle may not be
comfortable but if we can somehow emerge
victorious what a victory it will be our
medium is young but if we can help it
grow and we can use it to create it
means that we have accomplished
something beautiful and that
accomplishment should make us happy as
well there are certain things that are
part of our medium that no other medium
can claim to possess there are certain
parts of our medium that give us a
fighting chance first off in our medium
stealing is in most cases not
destructive because replication comes
for free sharing and utilizing others
code is widely accepted and expected
coding is
socially acceptable thievery this is not
to say you should go out willy-nilly and
Jack IP just that sharing is caring you
can see communities arise from the
sharing and it makes everyone involved
more mighty the best example of this
that I know is three J s because of one
man mister Dubes fervent dedication to
creating a useful library many other of
the power players of the WebGL community
have joined in in making a tool that
lets even someone like me who has no
idea what they're doing create something
it's more than just that though others
have let mr. Duke called their work his
own in this way altered qualia be
Houston Z Z eighty five zero three one
and many many others have added to the
community with selfless dedication with
each additional commits comes more
complexity more substance and more code
to steal it may be difficult to steal
directly from nature but in this way we
can we can create complex enough
networks of thievery that the stealing
itself becomes its own organic being for
the demo that I will show you I've not
I've stolen so much work from so many
people that there's no way that I can
have have claim to creative myself I've
only selected a mix of other others
works and put it together in a way that
I've not seen before all work we do is
not our own it is that of our community
even in the unlikely chance that you
have built something using no libraries
the work that the v8 engine does in
order to compile your code and even more
the work that intel or nvidia has done
in order to render your program trumps
any contribution that you could make to
the overall success of your application
any time you think you have made
something you are wrong you have
channeled the organic power of
communities corporations and people in
order to manifest a creation of humanity
I can't explain exactly why but the
miracle of these different components
coming together every time i refresh my
browser makes me think of the mixing of
milk and coffee that I love so much
suddenly my messy room the deadlines
coming up the fact that rent was due two
days ago doesn't matter so much and I
start drifting in mental space marveling
at the smallness of my own
accomplishment as I consider how
magnificent our species is I forget the
urgent and remember the important it
doesn't just stop the channeling of
humans though our medium has something
else that is spectacular
variables although I will never be able
to make a face that is better than the
one that Nature can make there's
something else magical I can do I can
change the skin color I can even change
the color of the lights that shine upon
the skin and I get to do all of this
with a single keystroke in this way I
can create an object that maybe has less
detail but has more self freedom than
that which is created by nature although
this goes a bit against letting nature
do to the work there's something special
about variables they can be controlled
by another manifestation of nature data
in my mind data is our most fierce
weapon in the creation of that which is
organic because it is so expansive it
allows us to pass through one piece of
nature to another although this
manifestation usually tends to be a one
one to one correlation say placing
population data on the globe there's
nothing to say that we can't recklessly
link two uncorrelated phenomenon imagine
a face whose features are distorted by
the number of endangered animals per
geographic unit I'm sorry I didn't have
time to make this but I hope that you
can concede it is at least possible in
this way we can begin to create works
which utilize data to create an
interface between between the natural
world and our
by figuring out ways to get real-life
data we get to make real-life
applications real-life art there are so
many sources of real-life data to me
there's like obviously infinite but
there are two that are the most
important what I hear and what I see I'm
not yet able to rig my eyes and ears up
to a thunderbolt cable but in the
meantime there are two ways that I can
begin to access these senses the Web
Audio API and leap motion
the Web Audio API is great because
anytime I want to link audio frequencies
to parts of an application all I need to
do is create a stream create an analyzer
and call it analyze function on the
update loop that's all it takes to get
access to natural data the leap motion
is great for a similar reason all I need
to do is create a controller connect it
and now I've access to something that I
can see something as fluid and authentic
as the movement of my own hands because
of the simple access to data I get to
start doing strange things with code I
get to start saying okay make a face but
also just deform it based on the sound
of my voice oh and also so that when I
see my hand turn make the colors change
suddenly something that I've stole comes
to life by funneling data from one place
to another
although I tend to fetishize the
aesthetic this fluid data is more than
just a visual nicety I've seen
interfaces that feel more playful and
organic than any I've experienced pre
leap motion and pre Web Audio API I've
seen things created that were never
before possible I myself learned to 3d
model and made a mug overnight thank you
yeah it's because all I had to do was
reach my hand into space and use the
senses that I loved so much because many
minds more brilliant than mine did find
a way to mine the data I get to lovingly
thieve their work through robust and
simple api's they make the data easy to
thieve and as creators that is the
kindest thing we could ask for
additionally because of their nuanced
connection with natural data programming
with the Web Audio API and leap motion
becomes a pleasure rather than a task
although mimicking the binary click of a
mouse may be less than ideal new
interfaces that deal with flow and
movement in the full spectrum of human
capability become possible because I can
make frequency of my voice control
scroll rate or use the position of my
hand to control the camera movement I
can readily change one piece of data to
another and this flow in my mind is
miraculous thievery it is because in our
medium there are no units creating a
hundred-foot sculpture only means
multiplying scale by a hundred linking
gravitational potential to note
frequency only costs a single line of
code if I want to change from X Y Z to
RGB there's absolutely nothing stopping
me and that is where WebGL steps it for
meet up on WebGL I think you might think
I would mention the technology earlier
than two-thirds of the way into the
speech but I hope that everything up to
this point will still apply to your
creation even if you never end up using
WebGL that being said you should use
WebGL you should use it because 3d is
ridiculously awesome you should use it
because you can make an entire
presentation in it and it doesn't take
that long but the biggest reason to me
that you should use it is because
shaders also it did take that long now I
only learned that shaders were the truth
and the light about two months ago so
please take the following with a grain
of salt
I'm feverishly studying how they work
and what they can do but that being said
it's only been two months this should
give you a lot of hope though because if
I can learn anything about shaders in
two months it means you can - I'll try
to talk about this a bit it's a bit too
much to talk about quickly but I'll give
you your sources - in the end web GL
shaders do two things XYZ and RGB XYZ is
to a vertex shader which positions every
single vertex and a geometry which you
see here as aq an RGB refers to a
fragment shader which colors every pixel
in that object together
the two can deform and color any shape
until it looks nothing like the original
we could do a full speech just about
deforming and coloring a cube in
interesting ways and I'm sure that if
you searched on the internet you could
find exactly that speech but we've got
to remember what we're here for is the
coffee to get there we need to do a few
tricks because we can sample textures
into vertex shaders we can easily
exchange XYZ with RGB basically placing
particles based on the RGB value of a
texture now I'm going to start with just
the picture where we take the RGB values
of the picture and place them around
based on the value of those three
objects so R becomes X G becomes y and B
becomes Z here we can see the pixels and
colors turn to positions and see that
although there are these deep reds the
yellows actually have value that
contains r g and b so it reveals
something fundamental about this picture
that we may have not known before we can
take this a step further and sample a
texture that we've created with a
fragment shader in this way we can color
each texture of a shader as we've done
randomly in the middle giving values
from negative 1 to 1 for r g and b and
then placing each particle as it
corresponds to its pixel in
3-dimensional space then by chaining
together vertex and fragment shaders we
can create one fragment shader that
talks about position and one fragment
shader that
about velocity once we link all this
through we can do something spectacular
a physics simulation done entirely on
the GPU what is so special about this is
that all the calculations happen in
parallel in this gravity demo every
single particle is in an acting
gravitational force on every single
other particle we're talking millions
and millions of calculations every frame
we're talking instead of hundreds of
particles you have thousands even
millions now I should have spent the
entire speech trying to explain this but
they're already a few brilliant examples
that you can look at mr. dibbs Pharrell
demo which was part of the Google
Christmas experience is a great example
and he's released all of his code Zizi
85 spark J s is absolutely sublime Z Z
85 also does a flocking demo into three
J s examples so check that out and as
well soul wires straight WebGL GPU
particles the tasks that they are doing
are all different but if you closely
examine them all you will learn
dramatically more about GPU than I can
hope to explain in this short time
however with their knowledge aptly and
lovingly stolen I could move on to the
holy grail turbulence to make my
turbulence I use something called curl
noise it is not actually fluid dynamics
and I've been told by a few math PhDs
that it's a sin to even call it mimicry
it's smoke and mirrors but then again we
are magicians now the most beautiful
example I've ever seen of curl noise was
from the astute creator Eddie Lee and
his demo artifacts as you can see here
Eddie Lee is a straight-up mastermind
and if you've ever played Kyoto or Lotus
I'm sure that you will understand why he
elegantly navigates the issues I've
discussed with digital creation both by
creating authentically organic shaders
and
or by buying wholeheartedly into the
fact that his creation cannot be natural
and making it playfully simple
additionally he's awesome because he let
me steal his code he showed me how to
mimic my turbulence my happiness
I didn't just steal code from him he
gave it to me free of charge and out of
kindness with this code in hand I was
off to the races
after hectically slapping together
shader code into ZZ 85s GPU particle
simulator
i refreshed my page and nothing happened
I did it again and again nothing after
multiple more hours of frustration that
can only be known by someone who is
tripped on a shoelace moments before
finishing the marathon I finally asked
one of my other idols Reza leave for
help being yet another brilliant mind in
another gracious soul Reza sent over his
curl noise code which made me realize
that I used an equal sign instead of a
plus equal sign for the most vital part
of the equation I told you I know
nothing about equality's but with that
bug fixed I crossed my fingers refresh
my browser and there it was my very
first turbulent system and by mine
I mean mr. Doo alter qualia Z Z 85 Eddie
Lee Reza Lee and probably many of the
people sitting in this room right now
sure it was no milk and coffee and I
know now that using more optimized code
I could get 10 times more particles but
it was a start and that alone made me
happy I really think that this could
have been enough for me if I committed
my changes shut down my computer and
went to sleep it would have been more
enough creation to gratify my gluttonous
desire for the important but if I
stopped it would just be a frail
imitation of nature
it will be dots algorithmically moving
around the screen and as happy as I was
with those small white squares it is
after this point of initial
implementation that our medium begins to
shine this piece of code is in my engine
forever now I get to play now I get to
create my happy place now I finally get
to explore in a way that was never
possible in the physical world that
sunset though heartwrenching only
happens once a day it will never be the
beautiful turquoise and magentas that I
can so lucidly imagined it to be
although I can watch the glowing ball
from far away I can never reach out and
touch it
yes we're stuck in simulation we are
perpetrators of imitation but in that
imitation in that mimicry comes a new
truth it is a hyper reality we create
that Sun can not only set in the East
but it sings to us if we only will it
the stars are no longer a diamond
curtain but a playground we can explore
and experience that which is not
possible nature may be a brilliant
artist but if we choose to create with
its infinite power we have to take on
the shackles of physicality now with
WebGL with access directly to the senses
we can begin to cast those shackles off
I'm no longer no longer limited to my
flesh self and I can finally come to you
as khabib oh the ice mandala of the
Northern Kingdom floating in the
darkness
nature may want to keep me here on this
earth harnessed by my decrepit human
form but I refuse that requirement I
will create a universe where I can fly
through the stars with the flick of my
wrist watch eons unfold which eat with
each harmonious home
I will reject common sense to make the
impossible possible
I will create
I will leave you now with one more of
our creations
please sit with me and as you watch its
life unfold meditate on what is
important to you and what makes you
happy
think about what you will do as a
miraculous creator and how you can
harness the power of the entire human
race to manifest your creation as I fly
you through our slowly dissipating
universe remember that although we will
always be painfully limited as humans we
together have made something that allows
us to be so much more without further
ado I give you we over by holy other
thank you and check these out